>> Bill: A SCIENTIST OUT OF
HONG KONG WHO SAID SHE WAS DOING
RESEARCH ON COVID-19 IN DECEMBER
AND JANUARY THAT COULD HAVE
SAVED LIVES, BUT SHE SAYS HER
SUPERVISOR SWEPT IT UNDER THE
RUG.
DR. LI-MENG YAN SAYS SHE ESCAPED
TO THE UNITED STATES TO TELL HER
STORY.
SHE JOINS ME LIVE FOR THIS
EXCLUSIVE CHAT TODAY.
WELCOME, DOCTOR.
YOU ARRIVED IN THE U.S. AT THE
END OF APRIL.
YOU BELIEVE THE CHINESE HAVE
LIED ABOUT WHAT?
>> YES, EXACTLY.
EXACTLY.
I HAVE TO HIDE BECAUSE I KNOW
HOW THEY TREAT THE WORKERS, AND
HERE, I WILL TELL THE TRUTH OF
COVID-19.
SO I HAVE TO --
>> Bill: WHAT’S AT THE CHINESE
LIE ABOUT THAT YOU CAN PROVE?
>> OKAY, FIRST, SO AS I
MENTIONED IN THE VIDEO, OUR
GOVERNMENT ALREADY KNOWS THAT
OVER 40 PEOPLE GOT INFECTED.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY, HUMAN TO
HUMAN TRANSITIONS ALREADY AT
THAT TIME.
THEN THEY MUTATE --
>> Bill: YOUR CLAIM IS THAT AT
THE END OF DECEMBER, THERE WAS
HUMAN TO HUMAN TRANSMISSION.
THE GOVERNMENT AND THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION DID NOT
CAPTURE THAT UNTIL ABOUT THREE
WEEKS LATER.
IF YOU ARE RIGHT, HOW WOULD
THINGS BE DIFFERENT AROUND THE
WORLD AND HERE IN THE U.S.?
>> OKAY, I EXPLAINED TO YOU.
FIRST, THIS IS A HUGE PANDEMIC
WE HAVE SEEN IN THE WORLD.
SO, THE TIMING IS VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT.
SO IF WE COULD HAVE STOPPED
EARLY, WE COULD HAVE SAVED LIVES
LIVES.
>> Bill: OKAY.
SO YOU HAVE SENT, THEN -- YOU
INVITED YOUR HUSBAND TO COME
WITH YOU.
HE DID NOT.
YOU HAVE SPOKEN WITH THE FBI.
WHO IS INVESTIGATING YOUR STORY,
DOCTOR?
>> THE FBI -- AND MANY OTHER
PEOPLE FROM THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
THEY HAVE CONTACTED ME.
THEY NEED TO VERIFY MY STORY.
>> Bill: OKAY, CAN YOU PROVE
IT, DR. MARK >> I HAVE THE
RECEIPTS OF THE FBI AGENT.
FROM THE LOS ANGELES AIRPORT.
SEVERAL DAYS LATER IN NEW YORK.
>> Bill: JUST TO BE CLEAR, NOT
WHETHER OR NOT YOU CAN PROVE
THAT HE TALKED TO THE FBI, OR
CAN YOU PROVE YOUR CLAIMS?
>> OH, YEAH.
HOW I COMMUNICATE WITH THE
PEOPLE IN CHINA AND ALSO BECAUSE
OF MY NETWORK.
WORKING WITH CHINA DURING
COVID-19.
AND ALSO, I CAN SHOW IT TO YOU
LATER.
>> Bill: OKAY.
SO YOU BELIEVE YOUR LIFE IS IN
JEOPARDY AND YOU WILL NOT GO
BACK TO HONG KONG.
HOW COME?
>> OF COURSE.
BECAUSE I KNOW HOW THEY TREAT US
US.
THE TRUTH, NOT ONLY ABOUT
COVID-19, BUT ALSO FOR THE OTHER
THINGS HAPPENING IN CHINA.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE PROFESSOR HAD
REVIEWED IN BEIJING, PUNISHED,
AND ALSO, IN SHANGHAI, REVIEWING
COVID, AND IN FEBRUARY THIS YEAR
YEAR.
SHUT DOWN BY THE GOVERNMENT.
>> Bill: THE CHINESE EMBASSY
HERE IN THE U.S., THEY DON’T
KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
THEY SAY WE’VE NEVER HEARD OF
THIS PERSON, REFERRING TO YOU.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT, DOCTOR?
>> OF COURSE THEY WON’T KNOW ME
BECAUSE I AM NOT -- KNOWING WHO
WORK DIRECTLY -- BUT I WANT NO
WORK VISA, AND I AM A TEAM
MEMBER TO COMMUNICATE WITH
CHINA.
>> Bill: OKAY, LAST QUESTION
HERE.
MAYBE I CAN REFRAME THE QUESTION
QUESTION.
WAS THE U.S. GOVERNMENT, WHAT
WERE THEY ABLE TO DO WITH YOUR
INFORMATION?
>> I AM WAITING TO TELL ALL THE
THINGS I KNOW, PROVIDE ALL THE
EVIDENCE TO THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
AND I WANT THEM TO UNDERSTAND,
AND I WANT U.S. PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TERRIBLE THIS IS.
IT IS NOT WHAT YOU HAVE HEARD --
EVEN THE W.H.O.
THIS IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
WE HAVE TO KEEP THE TRUE
EVIDENCE AND GATHER IT TO STOP
THIS PANDEMIC.
WE DON’T HAVE MUCH TIME.
>> Bill: IF YOU’RE RIGHT,
DOCTOR, YOU ARE SHOWING AN AWFUL
LOT OF COURAGE.
DOCTOR, THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.